We now discuss how to come up
with confidence intervals when
we try to estimate the unknown
mean of some random variable,
or of some distribution,
using the
sample mean as our estimator.
So here X1 up to Xn are
independent, identically
distributed random variables
that are drawn from a
distribution that has a certain
mean theta, the
quantity that we want to
estimate, and some variance
sigma squared.
Let us say that we want
to construct a
95% confidence interval.
Our starting point will be the
fact that the sample mean,
according to the central limit
theorem, can be described
approximately using normal
distributions.
And we look up at the normal
table, and we observe the
following--
that if we take a standard
normal random variable, then
there is probability, 97.5% of
falling below this number,
1.96, which means that there
is probability 2 1/2% of
falling above that number.
And by symmetry, the probability
of falling below
minus 1.96 is also 2 1/2%.
This means that this middle
interval here has probability
95%, and we exploit this
fact as follows.
If we take the sample mean,
subtract the true mean, and
then divide by the standard
deviation of the sample mean,
then we obtain a random
variable, which is
approximately a standard
normal.
Therefore, what we have here
is the probability of an
approximately standard normal
random variable.
Or actually, its absolute value
falling below 1.96.
This is just the event that
our standard normal falls
inside this middle interval
here, according to this entry
from the normal tables and the
previous discussion, this
probability is going to
be approximately 95%.
And now we take this statement,
send this term to
the other side of the
inequality, and then interpret
what it means for an
absolute value to
be less than something.
And we obtain an equivalent
statement.
This event here is algebraically
identical to the
event that we have up there, and
this provides us with the
desired confidence interval.
We think of this quantity here
as the lower end of the
confidence interval.
This quantity here is
the upper end of
the confidence interval.
And this statement tells us
that there is probability
approximately equal to 95% that
the confidence interval
constructed this way contains
the true value
of the unknown parameter.
So this is how we obtain a
95% confidence interval.
If instead we wanted a 90%
confidence interval, we would
proceed in more or less
in the same way.
Here, we would want to
have the number 0.95.
Why is that?
We want this middle interval to
have probability 90%, which
means that we want to have
probability 5% at
each one of the tails.
And then we look up at the
normal tables, and we find
that the entry that gives us
probability 95% of being below
that value is 1.645.
So if we use 1.645 in place
of 1.96, we obtain a 90%
confidence interval, and
similarly for other choices.
For example, if we want a
99% confidence interval.
There's only one issue that's
left to discuss, and this is
the following.
In order to obtain numerical
values for the endpoints of
the confidence interval, we
need to know sigma, the
standard deviation
of the random
variables that we are observing.
But if we do not know the value
of sigma, then we may
have to do some additional
work.